what's up Brad today we're trying out
something different something that
hasn't been done before we're reviewing
this subreddit I don't know who your
heart of this
it's called dank memes okay so is that
like memes but a little more in here
trigger warning on the screen right now
if you can't handle edgy humor then the
door is right there and it's free for
you to leave okay now without further
ado let's just jump into this I can't
believe this channel has absolutely no
shame whatsoever on the headphones I
didn't either people born in 1999 people
born in 2000 I basically become these
text-to-speech and reddit channels at
this point except I have to do the
actual effort of reading it out this is
the top voted me man pretty good
minecraft becomes the number one top
selling video game on its 10-year
anniversary happiness noise that's all
you sneezing okay know the context
behind the name or shut that freak out
of my face me struggles to open a jar my
ancestors who fought and tied to the
Crusades shame me when I make a another
reddit video and my nine year old
audience shame well I'm trying goddammit
feeling depressed just remember there is
someone out there getting friends owned
by a girl who wears cat ears to school
what are you insinuating will you press
the button I love these
Shrek becomes real but you have to marry
him what's the problem
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding Shrek babies
when replying instantly to my crush text
after she was busy for two days me
stupid toots well if you're dealing with
the kind of pot that has to play some
sort of social media online game with
then maybe she isn't worth it anyway
brofist if you're gay that's right on
this channel we don't discriminate
against lgbtq+ we acknowledge brofist if
you're gay USA banning huawei china
binding apple can i read English Samsung
smoking some weed
boy that's epic stop writing insults
about Alabama there are 50 in education
they can't read that [ __ ] haha they have
is it the first part not gonna like what
is happening in Alabama they banned
their gay Rhett marriage they can't do
that
Alabama let the gay rat wedding be but
the first day I swore let the goddamn
gay right wedding be you when you're
barbers bald but actually you see a good
haircut I got other stupas dented it's
so bad I guide others to a treasure that
I cannot push this all right so let's
get really this video is gonna get
garbage eggs but I have a way to get
past the system all right
5,000 IQ move coming up the
highest-valued
ads on YouTube are real estate so I'm
just gonna say a bunch of words when the
mid roll rolls and hopefully they will
transcribe properly and get the adding
you should buy a house are you looking
to buy a house if you're looking to buy
a house
I'm insurance you can buy one for cheap
perhaps get a mortgage
hey wait this Lincoln 10% will go to me
boy buy a house buy a very nice house
you should buy a house are you thinking
you're thinking about buying a house or
did you I can tell just by looking at
I'm hey Stackhouse want a goddamn
another house two houses three houses
that's awesome brofist if you're a gay
house okay let me know if you got a real
estate commercial happy 10th birthday
what in the gods are hizmet is this Oh
God
let me explain to my friend why I'm
spending three I was making minecraft
name my friend the FBI agent watching me
this reddit has turned into me IRL
congratulations you did it everyone
while reddit was down oh my god is that
the same cave
my doctor me explaining if I drink 18
million 5-hour energy dreams I will live
forever
coach PewDiePie please please guys cool
it glows in the dark
Elin must explaining the benefits of
catgirls Tesla space you know this has
been raised at some board meeting dice
you or do you understand the potential
here look how cute he looks now stop
hating on James Tati Westbrook urges her
followers to end all abuse after
starting scandal
hold on this whole operation was your
idea
your snake timeline twenty one thousand
five hundred sixty ant-man
aims for the wrong rate if you weren't
king it's a simple but quite unbreakable
that's lovely to see another game being
inclusion this joke is gonna bite me in
the ass it's almost gonna make a
compilation
you never saw up the 90s born in 1999
born in 2000 I will be 69 years old in
20 69 god damn it you know who else is
gonna be 69 years old this year
my man coming up soon my man my bra my
man
my honey my boob my [ __ ] my home
software uber driver that doesn't talk
to me the whole right fine stars why do
they just not get it no one wants to
talk to you okay if I wanted to talk to
you I would talk to you and if I
do you you scum it's only added courtesy
and you were supposed to still
understand that and not reply thank you
hurry this is the last time I hear that
is quote from you or else I'm leaving
you a price to pay for salvation
me and the boys like I'm not breasts in
the dictionary brah there's prices in
the dictionary borscht boys
that's a soup you dummy Germans Buddhist
what happened in the 60s huh what did
you do in the 60s
[Laughter]
now we know what happened in the sixties
glad we got that mystery solved when you
are swimming you have solute Schmucks
I'm not even English and you don't know
the difference between you are and your
dummy dumb when you are swimming and
your leg our leg brushes some seaweed as
a fellow Swedish man I can agree it's
freaking gross and we have to climb up
the rocks when we swim in this or
seaweed but then you get over it but you
know what we were doing right these
seaweeds and we would poke two holes in
one of them and we would tie them around
our face so we could look like the
turtles the Ninja Turtles it's awesome
sorry to interrupt to video gamers I
just want to let you guys know to
celebrate our road to 100 million
subscribers we re releasing all the 50
to 60 to 70 80 now that 90 million club
merged baby right now 60 million club is
available very epic check it out collect
them all support the channel because
this video is one percenter monetized
thank you by me places 8k kmt blocks in
one area okay my pc i don't like where
this is going 25 games like minecraft
you should try it fortnight how dare you
why is everyone so obsessed with
minecraft like chill what can I say
except me percent like the original
88.7 guys I fixed Australia there's so
many Elon Musk here I never realized I
don't get it I don't play minecraft I'm
not a nerd okay studies for four hours
mom no reaction checks my phone for
three minutes and me who just got
grounded
I am inevitable mom who took the
batteries incredible Game Boy Advance
that's it wasn't good
me trying to describe this one song I
heard in a video da-da-da-da-da I always
wonder if that works
Santos snaps pregnant god that's funny
okay yeah yeah yeah if you're preggers
right now don't worry if Thanos isn't
real this is totally fine as long as
you're not in Alabama laptops after five
minutes of work yeah they're not great
are they those are the fact that the
whole keyboard just can start heating up
too and you keep your hand there and
then you hang it so sweaty from the heat
of the laptop and then it gets like all
watery and then then your sweat
integrates the Intel system and then
everything cools again scientists
invented bracelet that gives an electric
shock to the wearer
oh my god please give me this what the
hell when you accidentally call it your
teacher mother but save it by saying
[ __ ]
real smooth oh yeah when you turn on
subtitles but the show has subtitles
built in what is he doing one of them is
a dictionary or something I can
understand but well God's earth is that
even possible
prawn star turned actress gives
interview me watching the interview on
TV hey I think I've seen there's woman
somewhere before
no that's when you go what who is this
new upcoming actress that I've never
seen ever before what gives people
feeling of power money status going
against the entire class getting the
answer correct basically me on the whole
James Charles stuff like
I mean Papa deloria's who's dead this is
so sad
do you want to buy a house I think
you're looking like someone that wants
to buy a house could I interest you in
some real estate could I interest you in
a lifetime of depth hmm how about a
property smash like subscribe and can I
interest you in buying a property what
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]